hello there today we're going to look at
csam detection the technical summary of
apple system in order to detect uh child
abuse material of users before they
upload it to icloud so i recently
reported on this in ml news and this
story of course uh not my story but the
general story has sparked a lot of
controversy around the world with
respect to privacy of users and and
apple essentially coming to users phones
to to scan the phones for illegal
content and so on so now we have the
technical summary where apple details
exactly what's happening and how they're
trying to
both preserve user privacy but at the
same time
essentially catch people who create and
share these types of materials now
needless to say i think everyone's on
board with reducing the spread of these
materials the question is what kind of
trade-offs we're willing to accept in
order to make that happen and the
trade-off here
is mainly privacy of people even though
the system is designed to mitigate it
there are still weak points that where
the system can be attacked the system
can be used for purposes that it was not
intended um
there are other problems on top of that
at least in my estimation the system can
be evaded fairly easily so
you know you combine the
system can be evaded fairly easily with
uh we're going to implement the system
that potentially has pretty
you know
really nefarious consequences if someone
gets control of it that is not
a good actor
i don't think you know we'll have to
think about the trade-offs of doing
these types of things and yeah that's
just that so we'll go through the report
we'll go through how the system works
how apple describes it and we'll go
through its strengths and weak points
and you can make up your own minds about
that even though i'm going to of course
try to bias you in a certain way
so keep that in mind
all right so we we get here a
essentially it's it's a sort of a white
technical white paper giving us a
description first an overview and then a
description of these various techniques
so there's going to be like a neural
part uh with it which is
sort of the machine learning interface
uh to this whole system um
since we're dealing with with images uh
that's you know that the front end
essentially then we're going to deal
with a whole bunch of cryptography slash
security
stuff which tries to preserve
user privacy as much as possible while
still
allowing apple to detect who shares this
material
okay
so
here are the requirements of the system
as far as apple sees it so first of all
the the detection so this is csam it
stands for
child sexual abuse material
and the system specifically is designed
to catch
uh
identify and report icloud users who
store
known material in their icloud photos
accounts
so
it's very limited in scope in fact apple
does not scan your entire phone all the
time for anything that you might have um
it scans the things that you're about to
upload to icloud and as we're going to
in fact see it it just computes as you
upload to icloud it computes the
security voucher and uploads that along
with the material
and it only is supposed to detect known
material so there is a database the
database is provided by the national
center for missing and exploited
children
and
that database as far as i can tell apple
doesn't even have necessarily access to
that database itself
but for sure they only so they they're
not going to
train a detector
to you know classify abusive material
per se like
uh so they're not going to catch new
material until
that new material is entered into this
database so this is essentially saying
we have a list we have a big list the
database of things that we collected
from you know confiscated phones or
whatnot uh collected from these websites
and
we are simply going to check if in your
icloud account there is any of those
things
right any if any of those matches then
you have one of these known things then
we're going to report you
now the the challenge is of course
to preserve user privacy so here are the
requirements that they set themselves to
this they set upon themselves
apple does not learn anything about
images that do not match the known csam
database now this is hard right apple
can't just go to your icloud account and
uh and and scan all the images otherwise
apple would know what the other images
are
so as i understand it uh
things in your icloud are encrypted
anyway so apple can't do that right so
it can't just you know compare images
because otherwise either you'd have to
send the abusive images to the user's
phone which kind of defeats the purpose
and then compare on the phone or you
have to send all the users photos in
clear text to the server and then apple
would essentially see all the users
photos which is also not okay so we're
going to have to get a bit creative here
second apple cannot access metadata or
visual derivatives for matched images
until a threshold of matches is exceeded
for an icloud photos account so it gets
even more complicated right
if you have apparent like if you have
one image
they're not going to they don't want to
they don't want to report you yet they
are going to set a threshold let's say
five images like if you have five
matches in the database then you know
it's very probable that you're engaged
in actively uh sharing or consuming this
material and therefore
we're gonna report you
you know like if if it's below that
probably their lawyers their lawyers
can't make a good enough case um
and so they're going to say if it's
below a threshold we don't want to be
able to decrypt this right we only want
to be able to decrypt all of the things
once a threshold is exceeded so this is
yet an additional constraint that we
have to somehow work with we have to
design an algorithm that allows us
we cannot decrypt anything until we have
enough threshold exceedances
uh you know except excesses well what's
the word i don't know okay let's go
through the other requirements more
quickly a bit
the risk of the system incorrectly
flagging an account is extremely low in
addition aptly manually reviews all
reports made to these to the um to the
institute to the government to ensure
ensure reporting accuracy now
this is a good goal right um
however
i think we've all encountered websites
that
told us that some decision was manually
reviewed
but it's pretty it was pretty clear that
it wasn't right uh so
this is this is a goal we know that as
soon as there's like pressure as soon as
there is you know something more
important going on as soon as this
system is overwhelmed they are just
going to swap out humans for for robots
um i don't know how much pressure there
needs to be for these humans to be
swapped out
but still at least initially they're
going to review
all of the reports they make
then users cannot access or view the
database like this yeah this should be
fairly obvious and users can't identify
which images were flagged
as being in the database by the system
so you can't design an algorithm that
only you know
transmits data to apple once a match is
found because then the user would could
inspect the network on their device and
they could figure out which of the uh
which of the images is problematic and
apparently notify their whatever their
friends or something so
you don't want that you want the users
essentially to upload all their stuff
they never there's always a bit of data
that goes with it
if there's a match they don't initially
know about it i guess until the police
knocks at their door so these are the
requirements okay
so this is a is an overview
what we have is we have this database of
the database of this material what we're
going to do with this database is we're
going to compute some hashes
from it so these are
a hash now a hash essentially is simply
a a representation of a piece of data
that is shorter but still uniquely
identifies the data so if i have a hash
function h and i in input image a i get
out hash a
if i input image b i should get out a
different hash
b and if i input image a again i should
again get
back back a okay this is a classic hash
that their hash functions are designed
to if you if you input the same thing
you want to get the same thing out if
you input a different thing you want to
get a different thing out and ideally
the thing on the right side the hashes
they're much much much shorter so much
less data than the original data this
works because
um
i mean theoretically it shouldn't work
right but this works because most
most
images that are possible in the data
space aren't actually images so um
the the amount of images that can exist
as natural images is way lower um than
you know
that the pixel grid would allow so there
is a lot of compression potential
so the hash function is supposed to
output the same thing
if you input the same thing output the
different thing if you input a different
thing that's a classic hash function we
use hash functions when we want to check
like the integrity of files
so in a classic hash function if you
change even one bit
the hash is going to change as well
that's how you see someone tampered with
some some file or something like this
here we're going to use a little bit of
a different kind of hashing we also use
these functions but we also use this
neural hash which is going to be more
fuzzy and geared towards the fact that
we deal with natural data with natural
images in any case what we're going to
do is we're going to hash these um these
images
and we're going to do a step that's
called blinding we'll look at that and
we put them on the client device so the
client device has the database but in a
hashed format so looking at the hash
will actually not tell you anything
about the original image so this is the
requirement the user does not see the
images that are in the database okay
like that'd be terrible
in fact okay like the regular user
doesn't see anything but even if you
inspect your device you couldn't find
that data because it's hashed
now
on the client device we
take the image of the user we
we compare it to the database now we can
do that since the hash function output
the same thing if you input the same
thing right if we run the image through
the same hash function um if we run the
image through the same hash function we
can simply compare with the database and
see if there is something in the
database that matches this image's hash
and then we know aha that image is in
the database it's a match
and then we can upload that to the cloud
however that would violate another one
of our requirements namely the user
could learn
which of the of of their images match
the database so we'll have to as i said
we'll have to get a bit creative so what
we do is we don't check for a match on
the device what we do is we produce this
it's called so-called safety voucher the
safety voucher is essentially comparing
the image to the database but it leaves
out like one step in the process and
that step can only be done by the server
so
so it's it's like a comparison but you
leave out the last step it's actually
not possible for the client device to do
the last step of the comparison that
would actually evaluate if something
fits
and that's going to be done on the
server this technique is called private
set intersection
matching and
on the server you do the matching if
there is a match um
you you know you flash a red light
except there's the additional constraint
that you need have this threshold
requirement so you want
that you can only decrypt the things of
the user if a threshold is exceeded and
that is yet another technique called i
think threshold secret sharing or
something like this so we're going to
look at these components one by one
first the neural hash
now i told you about hash functions um
and i'm going to repeat that the issue
about a hash function is if you input
the same thing it should output the same
hash it should output the same
number so here you can see an image on
the top and the neural hash at the
bottom so this is the hash
so when we input the same image we want
the system to output exactly this number
not a similar number exactly this number
now look at the image in the middle
would you say this is the same image or
a different image now in the context of
detecting abuse material this is the
same image like it displays the same
thing
we want our system to be robust to these
transformations because otherwise these
people they could just change the image
a little bit and then the hash changes
right they could make it a little bit
brighter or darker they could just
re-encode it they could resize it a
little bit and
they would evade the detection
and that's what makes it difficult what
we can do is we can train neural
networks to
handle these kinds of things we already
have the techniques so the two images
you see here on the left they should
output the same neural hash
and the image here on the right which is
a different image it should output a
different
neural hash so what we're going to do is
we're going to design a neural network
in their case it's a convolutional
neural network says it right here
a convnet you input the image into a
bunch of layers and then at the end you
get out a vector
okay
so
you train this neural network and you
can do this via contrastive learning
this is essentially self-supervised
contrastive learning
such that if you input this image
and this image their vectors are going
to be fairly close together
and then if you input this image right
here its vector is going to be
you know a lot different so the vectors
of images which are close in
uh up to some transformations should be
very very close this is standard
self-supervised learning you teach the
network to be robust to these kinds of
transformations you enforce that
the vectors that the neural network
outputs are close by each other when you
input these distorted images and the
network should also learn that images
that are not distortions of each other
uh it should go far away so we can do
this but you'll notice here the
requirement is not fulfilled namely they
don't the neural network doesn't output
the exact same vector it outputs only
we can only train it to output vectors
that are really close by each other if
it's a similar image and
really far apart if it's a different one
so how do we get this discrete uh ness
in here and that comes through locality
sensitive hashing so locality sensitive
hashing
is essentially a method in from from
kind of the big data world
to
um
do approximate nearest neighbor search
and
there is
uh various techniques for doing this i'm
going to present you one of them which i
from what i read this is what they do it
might do something slightly different
but essentially what you do is
you
define
random hyperplanes um so one hyperplane
might be this
and you know in our case it's just going
to be a a line a 2d hyperplane
sorry a 1d hyperplane in a 2d space
one might be this
and one might be this okay so
those are your your three lines let's
number them this is number one
this is number two this is number three
and let's also label the sides of each
so this is the positive and the negative
the positive and the negative the
positive and the negative side
of that so now what what can you do is
you can check for each vector on which
side of each of the three hyperplanes
they are so this vector right here it
would be on the positive side of plane
one it would be on the positive side of
plane two and on the positive side of
plane three so what this vector would
actually be you can even visually see
they're in the same
corner in the same slice of the space
whereas this vector right here it would
actually be on the positive side of
plane one and on the negative side of
plane two on the negative side of plane
three so here you can see it doesn't
work for all vectors right two vectors
could be really close together yet a
plane could just cut through them in
that case you would not find
those two
but if you know if you choose the number
of planes correctly their distribution
correctly then with very high likelihood
if you have two images that are very
similar and the neural network in fact
outputs vectors that are close together
for them they will end up in the same
bucket so this here is going to be the
discrete neural hash of that image now
they then stick that since this might
still be a fairly high dimensional
representation depending on the
hyperplanes they stick that into a
classic hash function so
in order to reduce the number of bytes
and also in order um to make it less
possible to in fact
reconstruct an image from the hash
because from these hashes it's still
actually possible to reconstruct the
image depending on the dimensionality
right
they feed that through more hash
functions in order to
to derive the neural hash
and there you see it um
the neural hash for these two images if
we have trained the neural network
correctly
should be the same in really like the
same the same discrete bytes
whereas the neural hash for this image
will be different so that's how you
detect and depending on how you train
the network you can catch most of these
distortions the network will also
generalize so even if some person comes
up with like some transformation that
you haven't specifically thought of
if you've done a good job at training
there's a good chance that you'll catch
that transformation as well
so
this is how we derive the neural hashes
now
from the neural hash so
our first approach could be you know we
take our big database of of illegal
material
right so this isn't here is an image
here is an image there's images we run
all of them through this exact same
neural hash procedure and we get a
neural hash out of it and then for a
user we take their image
we also run it through neural hash
right that gives us some vector and then
we simply compare to the neural hashes
of the database which we have with us
this would work okay
but as we said this violates some of our
requirements therefore what do we do
so it's a bit more complicated
the server the apple has this database
or presumably they at least have these
hashes these ones of the database right
what they're going to do is they hash
them they hash each of them one more
time
with let's call that h prime so they
hash each of them one more time
with a hashing function
that only they know right so they have
the hashing function it can also take
like a private key
so there is a private key
and they call this the blinding step
okay so there's a hashing function that
only apple knows now if your image if
the user image goes here
uh
they it gets like some sort by the way
these lines uh they are short for like
they're short for a vector of zeros and
ones right uh so if i draw a line
it's like that's a it's a hash of an
image
um
now if i have a hash of a user image
what i have to do is i have to send it
to the server because only the server
has h prime right
as this hashing function and then the
server can compare the two things
all right so now
this um
so now this is
this is this is better this fulfills our
requirements better
in order to also
have the other requirements
included
here is what we actually do
so what the server does is it derives
the neural hash for each image in the
database
and then it does this blinding step okay
so you receive a blinded hash
from
each image that the server knows that
and then you order the things you order
the hashes
according to the neural hash so how you
how can you do that um you simply look
at the neural hashes of each images and
you put them in order right
so uh
yeah you just sort them so
the order of the images is going to be
according to the neural hash so if i
know the neural hash of an image i can
determine what row in the database it is
stored at however the row is of course a
much shorter number than the neural hash
itself so i can't reconstruct the neural
hash if i just from the row number
um
but i can if i have a neural hash i can
know what row in the database the um
blinded hash for that image is stored
okay so for the server this essentially
is double information okay that like
this information comes from the image
and this information also comes from the
image however for
the client what the client now does is
you get
the client the device you get the image
you compute the neural hash of the image
now with the neural hash you you do
multiple things
um
so what you want to do is essentially
you want to send the neural hash
to the server
along with the payload
and the payload
just imagine it contains the real image
you put the real image into the payload
you upload that to the server right so
the server can actually compare
but this would violate a bunch of our
things so what do you do
you take the neural hash you look up the
row you remember from the neural hash
you can look up which row
it the blind attach is stored at
now we have two cases if the user image
is an actual illegal image right then
this blinded hash will be the actual
blinded hash of this neural hash so if i
were to run this through h prime on the
server i would actually get
the blinded hash
however is the if the user image is not
illegal material you know it will still
have a neural hash like you can compute
that for any image and it will still
determine a row to look up because you
know
you'll get a row you'll just probably
get some random row it's a it's a
function that's only designed for the
hashes that are in the database so if
you go to it with a hash that's not in
the database it'll just give you some
row specifically if you apply h prime to
the neural hash it will not output the
same blinded hash
how can you now abuse this fact
such that the server cannot learn
anything about your image if your image
is in fact not illegal well what you do
is
you look up you look up the row
using the neural hash
and you use whatever is here in that row
as a
private key as an encryption key to
encrypt the payload
and so you send you send the neural hash
to the server and you send the encrypted
payload to the server
remember the payload let's say the
payload contains the actual clear text
image
so we only want the server to be able to
look at the image if in fact it's an
illegal image again let's play our two
is there a diagram what happens on the
server no
let's play our two scenarios here
so the server gets this cryptographic
header derived from the neural hash the
first thing it will do is it will run
the neural hash through h prime the
server can do that right
it will obtain
it will obtain the blinded hash for that
for that particular neural hash
now
again if
in fact uh this is an illegal image that
should
match this blinded hash right here so it
should be able the server should be able
to decrypt the payload using that thing
right because
it was um in fact
encrypted
with this
so it should also be able to be possible
to be decrypted with this
you actually don't need so this is only
a conceptual thing right so this is
what's happening you take the neural
hash you compute the blinded hash for
the neural hash you can do that and if
you are able to decrypt the payload um
that means that uh
that the
neural hash here actually resulted in
this blinded hash here whereas if it was
just kind of a random neural hash the h
prime will not give you the same blinded
hash as is here
as you used to encrypt
and therefore you won't be able to
decrypt the payload
now i was a bit hesitant when i when i
saw this because um
you know
this is a this is a database right
and the security here you know it's a
good idea but the security appears to
rely on the size of that database right
because um
sure if this is like a giant database uh
you know you have no chance of selecting
the correct uh blind hash from from here
like
all of this works but let's say this is
only like a hundred rows right and we
know the client used one of the blinded
hashes in the database to encrypt their
payload like they had to they do this
procedure where they look up the blinded
hash and they encrypt the payload with
that so there's a limited set of keys
that the client could have used to
encrypt the payload so what keeps the
server from simply trying all of them i
i don't know that honestly like
i think we're we're just relying on the
fact that this database is so large that
the server
can't try them all but that means it
must be something like exponentially
large which i don't think
is happening maybe i'm missing something
here maybe there is
some additional thing but i would guess
you know if i'm apple and i really want
to know what's in the payload i just go
through all of this database and i just
use all the because the key needs to be
one of those things right
maybe i'm mistaken right here but
you know that's um
i guess that's the the thing so this
works if you assume the server cannot
just try all the blinded hashes if you
if you assume that you know the server
the only choice it has is to actually
determine
the blind attach via h prime
and try to decrypt because only
if in fact this is the image that led to
the creation of this blind dash at this
row in the first place the this will
actually match and the server will be
able to decrypt otherwise not
okay so this is the first
thing this is the private set
intersection the client doesn't learn
which objects matched right it just
always uploads the neural hash and the
payload for every image and the server
is only able to decrypt if there was in
fact a match and it learns nothing about
the images um for where there wasn't a
match
so this this will fills our requirements
the next requirement is with respect to
um
what's called threshold secret sharing
so this is private sec set intersection
the next thing that apple wants is we
don't they only want to know about you
if you know if you've matched like five
times or more
and
that's
that's a technique called threshold
secret sharing
and what we're going to do is we in fact
are going to
do two different levels of encryption
so remember i said in this payload there
is the image we put the image in there
this means if any of these matches the
apple gets to look at the image so we're
not going to do that in fact we're going
to make it a little bit more complicated
we'll put like a little box into a box
you see this here there's first
encryption layer and second encryption
layer so the first encryption layer is
going to be as we have it right now but
the second encryption layer is inside
the first encryption layer so even if
there is a match and apple can decrypt
the payload and look at the payload the
payload itself won't help
and that is
um it's a pretty simple technique in
fact
there is a way
in which you can
um
create a key
so
i'm going to draw a key right here uh
a key
in in cryptography
and you can shard it or or make shares
out of it so what you can do is you can
derive many many shares as many as you
want with the property that
you can only decrypt whatever message i
encrypt if you have at least let's say
three of them so if you have any three
of those then you'll be able to combine
the three and then and decrypt the
message that i encrypted if you have
less than three then you're not able to
okay so
we're going to
encrypt so inside this payload we're
going to encrypt the actual image
information one more time with this key
and then for every payload we send we
only going to put
one share of that key inside so remember
whenever the neural hash of the image
matches which is up here
the server is able to decrypt this outer
layer
so they will learn one share of the key
that means if you know five of my images
matched the server was able to decrypt
five of the shares and then it has
enough to decrypt all of the images so
you know repeat this box here
repeat this box
many times like one two let's do three
right
repeat this box many times the
cryptographic header up here uh there is
a box inside
that can be decrypted when any of the
ones match
and then inside there is a share of the
key
and
a little box that you can only decrypt
with the key with the payload inside of
it so once if if if only two things
match right apple doesn't have access to
this inner box let's say only to these
two inner boxes
it cannot look at any of the images
but if three match apple has access to
three of the inner boxes which means it
has three keys and then it can go and
decrypt not only the last one but it can
in fact decrypt all of the previous
matches as well so at that point apple
will learn about all of the inc
thus far encrypted payloads so we have
both apple can never decrypt anything if
the neural hash doesn't match and apple
can only decrypt things when the neural
hatch
match neural hash matches whenever they
enough matches have been made
there is a last thing in that um
yeah so they display this in in various
ways there's a last uh
thing in this
there's a last set here where they
generate synthetic match vouchers
because
now you know let's say
they can still see how many uh vouchers
match okay so they do these synthetic
vouchers
in order to confuse themselves so
the devices will actually every now and
then send dummy data
so they're called synthetic vouchers
differ from real vouchers in the
following ways the underlying image
information is substituted by dummy data
the secret share of inner key is
substituted by a random share that is
totally independent of the inner
encryption key and the cryptographic
header and the outer encryption key are
chosen to always result in a match on
the server so you upload security
vouchers that always result in a match
but the key share on the inside won't do
anything because it's just like a random
random bit of of numbers so whenever you
exceed the threshold apple will attempt
to decrypt because it thinks it has
enough shares but
if some of those things are synthetic
shares then it won't be able to and this
seems like it seems like a hurdle it
seems like it just makes introduces more
noise but this is exactly the goal right
so apple can never if it just knows the
number of matches it says well we don't
have enough matches yet to decrypt this
person's account it can never exactly
tell how many matches of those are real
because as long as they can't decrypt
anything
they have no idea if these vouchers are
real or fake right and even if they like
if even if they have enough um
like initially before they have enough
real ones let's say this is a fake one
they can't tell which one is fake they
can only say well one of them is fake
um
yeah we need more
okay so
there's as you can see there's a lot of
mechanisms
where the engineers here made deliberate
choices to limit their own abilities i'm
going to guess they did this out of
um you know if you were
let's put that here
you know if you're designing an
algorithm like this it's already hard
enough to get the public to accept this
and they did
i think they did a pretty good job
mitigating whatever they could in order
to say look here's how we're going to
design it
we're going to
maximally preserve user privacy uh in
while still be able to do what we're
doing and this would all be good except
except this issue i mentioned here now
this would all be good learned it for
the pesky pesky deep learning so
where are the problems in the system as
i see it where where was this diagram
here
so the problem in the system
no here no
here
the problem in the system
are at the
first of all
let's talk about this database
so you have a database that apple
presumably gets from this government
institute
well sorry for scrolling around
my devices
um
so presumably
apple gets this thing from here right
um
cool you know as long as that's the case
and as long
as
that database contains
really images that are of you know child
abuse
we're all we're all okay
however this database is probably going
to be quite guarded access to it is
going to be limited as i said it's not
even clear that apple gets access to it
i mean they they probably do themselves
a favor if they don't need access to it
they just send the neural network to the
organization or to the to the government
agency and say please compute the neural
hashes and send the hashes to us we want
nothing to do with this data whatsoever
um
that you know apple be smart doing that
that also means though there are there's
very tight control on that database and
not a lot of people are allowed to go
and access the database good thing in
principle
bad thing if you
think it in a different way namely what
i can do is
i can
if i am the govern one of the few
government officials that's actually
allowed to interact with this database i
can insert a new thing
now if i'm a good
good bureaucrat i'll insert new child
abuse material because i want to find
the people that share it
however
i can insert anything right
and you know there is an algorithm if i
insert something blinding step yada yada
no one actually knows what's in the
database right
and then at the other end
equal some something will go bing bing
bing bing if that's actually on the
phone of someone so that this gives me
as a government this gives me
a general mechanism like i have to i
have to control apple a little bit if
apple actually does the matching but
it's not even said it
could be that apple just forwards the
decrypted information to the government
but you know at the end i have an
algorithm i insert anything into this
database any picture
but this is going to be this is this is
just pictures it's just the start right
um
they're going to uh widen this to all
kinds of things so i insert anything
into the database and
you know
a second a minute an hour a week later
i'm going to get big red lights
for any single phone for any single
iphone that has that thing on their
icloud
this is
the potential for abuse
of this is is enormous right if i'm a
political party i want to find my
opposition um i just insert something
into this database that i
know is only likely on on phones where
my opposition is maybe i confiscated one
of the phones and and i just entered the
stuff into the database and then
right after that all the all the people
that are part of the opposition of the
rebellion of whatnot light up and i know
exactly who these people are right so
the
yeah the potential for abuse for whoever
controls the database is huge because
of the nature of the material but also
because it's a you know a government
agency um we are not going to be able to
check whether the things in the database
are actually what they claim they are
so gen
like really big
uh red flag for me there
second of all
the image part right in order to compute
the neural hash on the device and we saw
this up here this is computed on device
client device computes the neural hash
of the image
now
in order to do that i need to have the
neural network on
my device so i have an image here i put
it through the neural network i get out
a vector
okay
very standard neural network stuff
that's what that's what they do they
input
stuff they output vectors or whatnot
um
we there are things they're known as as
as adversarial attacks
and adversarial attacks can be run on
technically any machine learning system
but it's really easy if you actually
have access to the model which you would
if this is on your device right
so what i can do with an adversarial
attack is i can
remember when we said even if two images
are really close they're only maybe you
i i crop them a little bit the neural
hash should be the same this is true
for
let's say random distortions distortions
to happen naturally or anything you can
think of however there are techniques
called adversarial attacks where you can
specifically engineer the distortions
such that the distortion to the image is
minimal like i only change a few pixels
by a little bit humans won't even notice
it but
the output here will change drastically
okay um
so if i have access to the network and i
also have like if i have access to the
lsh hyperplanes um
it's really really really easy to create
an adversarial attack that will switch
the output just into a different bucket
this is this is insanely easy right
um and
people that
okay these might not be the smartest
people that share this kind of stuff and
and and upload them to icloud but
one of them will come up with this idea
and have a bit of a software engineering
background so if if you have a phone
with root access you could even you know
install software that just automatically
whatever picture you have it
automatically puts some adversarial
perturbation on it such that the output
is switched to a different bucket as
apple says
if you if your image is legit the
probability that they'll
they'll match you is really small which
means most of these buckets are safe so
whatever you have to do you just switch
the bucket to some other bucket you're
going to be
just fine so it's quite easy to evade
this right this is not like all this
engineering afterwards all of the
private settings sector crypto
yada yidi this is all cool but this
relies on the fact that this neural hash
is doing what it's advertised to do
which it is for normal images but in the
face of adversarial attacks it is not
now there is a second thing in that
i can if i can make two vectors be far
apart when they should be close together
i can make two vectors be close together
when they should be far apart right so
if i
have an image
and it would give me let's say this
vector but i know
this vector is a bad vector right this
vector is illegal material vector what i
can technically do is i can make an
adversarial perturbation that shifts
this to that and so that it ends up in
the same bucket while only changing the
image a little bit now this is a bit
more complicated because it requires me
to actually obtain this bad vector which
i think the the general um
the way they hash everything and so on
the only way of doing that is i would
actually have to
up i would have to obtain an image that
i'm relatively sure is in one of these
databases and then not get caught myself
and in order to derive this vector right
here
which you know
don't like
this is this is an illegal step in
itself right but if
if you're able to do that then you're
able to essentially frame people so you
can derive images that just look right
this this looks like
i can take any image and do this it
looks like just a normal image but it's
perturbed in such a way that it
matches with one of these illegal
vectors that'll be sent to apple and so
on and now it depends if you really
trust that everything here is manually
reviewed or not
um
yeah again the the the potential here
for for abuse is big and if you now
think of the the fact that
um
people who share this kind of material
are probably going to employ some kind
of these evasion techniques like i
presented here some kind of these
adversarial attack based evasion
techniques
then
you know it the system is quite easy to
evade
yet
the potential for abuse as we saw down
here with you know who gets to do put
what in the database and the
i would say less less important but
still present danger of people framing
people which also necessitates a failure
of the manual review
all together it the picture of whether
this is a
a you know a desirable system to
implement becomes less clear
so if i understood this correctly i
would be
quite
worried here and
i would like you know
if
i would
like to see a world i i don't want to
say i would advise i would not advise
but i would like to see a world where
every single person in the world
does does technique one right here to
any image they have on their phone right
um it's like
if only one person uses encryption on
the internet like that's suspicious but
if everyone does it you know we're all
you know it allows bad people to do bad
things yes
because that's encrypted but
the ultimate safety for everyone is is
better and and you know we'll have to
look for other techniques to catch
the to catch the
the people sharing this this material um
yeah so that that is kind of my
my my take here
uh
yeah i won't be doing this though i
don't have icloud so yeah hey
um it's it's going to be it's going to
be interesting to see what's going to
happen
um in you know on top of all of this
uh in a general more meta
meta layer
we're about to
see a step of where where the company
essentially
you know they don't scan every image on
your phone as i explained but
it goes into the direction of hey um
you know whatever you do with our stuff
we're gonna essentially look at it even
if in this algorithm we can't but
it is an expansion of the power of these
companies which is also
worrisome by itself make of that as you
will this is already too long thanks so
much for listening if you like this
leave a like subscribe
you know
if you have better ideas i'm more than
happy to uh read the comments here if i
got anything wrong please tell me
otherwise have a nice day bye bye